thân hông an nghe an phà nêm dây quận bản pháu, thu dữ hơn 2 phía bà tạo pháu lâu.
Theo thông tin từ công an nghe an, phong cạnh sát hình sự phát hiện lối tượng đặc đất phương,
xin ngâm một nghiên tri chàn tảm iba, chủ tại Pâm Vinh Tân, thải phó Vinh, có sấu hiệu phạc tội hiết quán định pháu,
ý đã móc lời về một la sế khác là lấy bần dần, xin ngâm một nghiên tri chàn tảm tảm mấy tảm, với với vì với Vinh Vốt,
để môi sử lượng lượng phó lâu, tất cả phù chia về Việt Nam, sự cất giấu trong tụng sốt để việc trang Trung với hàng hóa trên dây tài.
Sơ bần truyền về tập két tại ngà dinh ở thành phố Vinh, sau có trình theo dõi,
ác sự tổn hợp các định hát nghiệp phụ, tối nghe mấy bệnh tảm mời, phong cạnh sát hình sự chủ chi,
phối hợp phong nghiệp phụ công an tình, công an định ghi lộc, công an phùa vinh đàn thịt Vinh,
đơn biết phong cửa khẩu có thể hà lưu, bất sức đặc đức vương khi đối tượng đàn bóc sế phảo tại nhà dưng,
lây sẽ ủ tốt tại để đi tự thủ tụt, tăng bật tru dữ,
là một chân sống mới mốt khuy phong lộ nhận dự nước ngoài có tổn vữ lượng là hai chăm mối bà phía bà phía lưu gâm,
đối chân mở giống trên an, tên nè mấy tảm lĩnh nghe hai môi tháng mời, phong cạnh sát hình sự bất sức phát xử phía vây gần dần.
Nguyễn quan ngăn, cũng nằm đối tượng khác trong đường dây bùng bán tảng trữ phật trự có lộ tự nước ngoài vây gian sau dần vương bà năng cập đầu.
Tổn xúc phá chuyện nán thú dữ có khó lượng là hai chăm bà bực lúc gà.
Hãy xem tổn, bún nhận tả gì đâu, phong cạnh sát hình sự đăng kép tục đối chân,
làm giống, sử lý cấp đối tượng theo quy địch pháp lột.